was gefährlich ist ist natürlich die
große zeit bahn kann dinge mit 1000
leuten 1000 leuten ja wirklich hinten da
drinnen ja muss ich mal zählen also 100
davon dass vielleicht auch ein cellist
oder ein sessellift mit vier plätzen
zweimal gesetzt das sind dann eher
enttäuschen oder ein skilehrer mit einem
gast da ist die ansteckungsgefahr viel
geringer als immer gleichen zeit unter
stadt also im gebirge den fällt deswegen
unterwegs dann dorthin gehen wo die
meisten einfach nicht sind weil wir uns
verlieren können die gäste haben platz
wenn sie sich in der landschaft
verlieren und das ende ich nicht nur
jetzt in der korona krise das seit ich
schon sehr lange
leider ist das eben selbst noch nicht
geschult er kommt in die alpen um diese
hohe die haben halt die stille zu
genießen und kommt dann und geht dorthin
wo alle anderen sind und deutschland
legal ist und dort entsteht dann hektik
inflation unruhe verbaute landschaft
genau das gegenteil von dem wasser
gesucht